thank you ted the chip shortage has
delayed the production of new cars but
at findlay subaru of las vegas the
sponsors of this segment they have great
options in the pre-owned market take a
look
[Music]
good morning hey buddy good to see you
man good to see you too jc i'm loving
the ram rebel you have here at subaru
las vegas this is a gorgeous truck you
guys had it is amazing i mean you know
look at the kind of used cars we get
here at super las vegas yeah you have
your freelance subaru's and you have a
fleet of pre-owned vehicles is the
market pretty hot for pre-owned cars
they are it's really hot people are
either selling their cars to us or
they're trading them in obviously on new
subarus and they're great vehicles you
have here they sure are is that whole
chip shortage i think right now with the
new cars it really is i'd love to talk
to you about it if you want to go inside
we can do that let's do it let's beat
the heat okay let's go
burton i feel like in 2021 with this
chip shortage there were no new cars
have these got any better this year they
are starting to get better jc we're
seeing maybe two or three cars out of a
uh a truckload that are actually
available for people to buy if someone
wants to get a new car what's the best
way to come have a dealership and look
or just still kind of an online process
i would start online uber of las
vegas.com and see what's cause we'll
show you what's available what's even
coming in that hasn't been spoken for
yet and also you have your huge
selection of pre-owned vehicles there as
well that's the really you know what
that's what we have going on right now
is we have a great selection of used
cars i have about 130 right now on the
lot use pre-owned cars that are just i
mean all kinds all makes and models
everything from subarus that ram we saw
outside there are you guys buying cars
right now as well yes we are kelly blue
book instant cash offer buying center so
you can go on to kelly boo book or
kbb.com you can value your trade and you
can select us as the dealer and come in
here bring your trade in and it'll it'll
tell you how much you're going to get
we'll verify that when you get here the
key word is verify right yes make sure
you don't be lying when you do your
kelly blooper evaluation you got to be
honest and then burn will take care of
you that's right someone's watching
right now and they're thinking about
selling their car bringing it in for a
trade-in are there certain things they
can do to their vehicle to maybe
increase the value you know i would say
make sure it's running good
get it washed if you want to detail it i
mean it doesn't cost a lot of money make
it look really good bring it on in here
let it let it present itself in the best
possible life could you show me one i
sure can let's do it okay
burton you weren't kidding about having
a huge selection of pre-owned vehicles
you got a tesla here yeah it's beautiful
isn't it yeah it's gorgeous this is a
perfect example of someone that wanted
to sell their car and so they got online
they went to subaru of lasvegas.com
and it says sell us your car and they
went on there they valued their trade
and made an appointment brought in and
we cut them a check you guys make it so
easy yes absolutely something else you
guys do you're always giving back to the
community you always have big events
coming up what do you guys have coming
up next we got some great events coming
up jc uh just one project pop and give
volunteer day that is at jd smith middle
school in north las vegas on september
24th burton i love it you guys are
always giving back to las vegas it's so
special thank you so much thank you jc
before the new owner comes can i take a
closer look at that absolutely pop that
thing over take a look at this thing oh
so quiet
call findlay subaru of las vegas call
them at
702-495-2100 take advantage of the
special offer 2.9 financing for well
qualified buyers for up to 48 months on
select 2022 models